وصلوا محتاجين تدفق الى الميادين في مدن
تل ابيب وبئر السبع وحيفا والقدس الغربيه
لتظاهر ضد حكومه اقصى اليمين برئاسه من
يمين نتنياهو
هذه الميادين منذ ثلاثه اسابيع مظاهرات
دعت اليها احزاب المعرض ومنظمه المجتمع
المدني وحركه
جوده الحكم
بالانقلاب على النظامين القضائي والقانوني
لتدريئه ساحه قادته المتهمين والمدنين
بيتها من تشمل الفساد وتبييض الاموال
داني شويه
وليد العمري وليد هذه المظاهرات مستمره
ومتواصله حتى الان ولكن ما هي اصداؤها
وتاثيرها على الحكومه الاسرائيليه
[موسيقى]
الحكومه الاسرائيليه الرئيس
تقديرات الشرطه وايضا المنظمين لهذه
المظاهرات اليوم ترجح ان اعداد المشاركين
تزيد على 130,000 في كافه المظاهرات هنا
في تل ابيب في الحال من الخلفي هناك
مظاهره اخرى في تلاميذ في موقع اخر واولاد
مظاهره في بئر السبع وكذلك في القدس
الغربيه وفي حيفا لذلك المنظمون انها
تزداد
ويعولون على ان الاستمرارهم لاطول لمده
ممكنه ان يكون عامل ضغط على هذه الحكومه
ويمنعها او يردعها من ان تواصل مشروعها
الخاصه بما يصفونه الانقلاب على القانون
ونظام القضائي لانهم يرون بان ما يسعى
اليه الى نتبعها ايه يافطه الاصلاحات انما
هو محاوله لوصول لمرحله يستطيع فيها تعيين
القضاه ليخرج بريئا هو وحلفائه المتهمين
والمدنين بتهمه فساد وايضا بيتها من اخرى
هناك شعارات ايضا تتهموا نتنياهو حكومته
بانهم مافيا وبانهم مجموعه من الفاسدين
واخرى تدعو الى اسقاطهم باسرع م- اا فتره
ممكنه ال- ال- المشاركون في هذه المظاهرات
التي زادت دخلت في اسبوعيا الثالث هم
تقريبا من كافه قطاعات المجتمع الاسرائيلي
ولا يقتصر فقط على احزاب المعارضه الاهم
ان هناك من المجتمع المدني ومنظمات اهليه
مختلفه وايضا اكاديميين وعسكريين السابقين
بعضهم ايضا من الاحزاب اليمين نفسها غير
راضي عن الخطوه التي يتجه في هذا الياهو
ويرون بانها مقدمه للعنصريه وربما لفصل
العنصريه شعارات رايها في هذه المظاهره في
تجري قرب وزاره الدفاع في تل ابيب وهي
مظاهره ضخمه بشكل الالافيت نحن فقط
اضطرارنا الابتعاد قليلا بسبب تعثر عمليه
البث لكن اعداد المشاركين كبيره للغايه
الموجودين هنا هم يرون بان اسرائيل اذا
نجح نتنياهو بتمرير مشروعه فانها لن تكون
اسرائيل التي يعرفها كما قالوا وانها
ستنتهي كنظام الديمقراطي حسب تعبيرهم وانه
في نهايه المطاف انما يعمل لمصالحه ومصالح
مجموعه شكرا اليمين المتطرف المتحالفه معه
وبعضهم قد هديل وبعضهم ايضا متهمين مختلف
مدير مكتب الجزيره متحدثا من تل ابيب شكرا